[Aplausos]
[Música]
había una vez un rey y una reina que
vivían en el castillo más hermoso del
mundo todo el mundo quería vivir en este
castillo y en eso llegan unos
extranjeros con el ejército mucho más
poderoso mucho más fuerte y conquistaron
el castillo treinta años después
regresan los de la ciudad y dicen pues
cómo es posible que nos pudieron
conquistar como podemos podemos hacerle
para reconquistar los en y en eso un
soldadito dice yo tengo una idea nos
separamos en tres uno del lado derecho
otros del lado izquierdo y otro nos
quedamos en el centro dos de los lados
vamos silenciosamente y atacamos al
ejército
a la fuerza se van a tener que separar
en dos y van a dejar el centro libre y
así los del centro van a poder van a
poder pasar y lo re conquistamos suena
fácil no entonces todos los demás le
dijeron estás loco no va a funcionar
está muy simple no no va a funcionar
estás loco hice pues mínimo soy el único
aportando
sé que va a funcionar en eso le hicieron
caso se separaron en tres uno del lado
derecho otro del lado izquierdo y otros
se quedan en el centro dos de los lados
silenciosamente se van y los empiezan a
atacar y efectivamente el ejército se
separa en dos y dejaron el centro libre
entonces los del centro empiezan a
caminar
el soldadito tenía razón no había nadie
y siguieron caminando y no había nadie y
siguieron caminando y no había nadie y
llegaron a las puertas del castillo
sacaron a todos
y lo reconquistaron
esto fue la reconquista de españa
esto sucedió en 10 minutos si ellos
pudieron reconquistar españa en 10
minutos que es lo que tú puedes hacer en
tan sólo 10 minutos mi nombre suena
sofia garza y les voy a contar lo que yo
pude hacer en 10 minutos
voluntariado monterrey es una plataforma
que promociona eventos de asociaciones
civiles de igual manera
creamos voluntariados para invitar a la
sociedad que se involucre en el bien uno
de nuestros nuestros proyectos más
importantes es el día de las buenas
acciones el día de las buenas acciones
nos trajimos hace dos años desde israel
que lo empezaron allá en el 2007 y hoy
en día participan más de 108 países con
más de 20 mil proyectos y más de
3.500.000 voluntarios
nuestro objetivo aquí en monterrey como
el día de las buenas acciones es hacer
buenas acciones como por medio de una
alianza con una asociación civil y con
nosotros y así creamos un voluntariado
en conjunto e invita
los demás que se unan promocionamos las
buenas acciones como por medio de
activaciones como ira santero de pinta y
las plazas comerciales o dar este tipo
de pláticas y celebramos las buenas
acciones como lo hacemos pues por
nuestros eventos sociales y por nuestro
día y evento más importante que es el
día de las buenas acciones más de seguro
se están preguntando que que hace una
chava como yo practicándoles pues yo
vengo aquí con experiencia y motivación
a platicarles algunos tips que ustedes
pueden asimilar a sus vidas y así porque
yo estoy segura que cada persona que
está aquí aunque tenga una pequeña idea
la puede hacer real más yo no puedo
hacer esto solo yo lo tuve que hacer en
un equipo entonces desde mi pc herita
decidí saltear al océano y en ese salto
al océano conocí a maría mi socia maría
y yo tenemos vidas muy diferentes ella
se fue a áfrica a salvar vidas fue
colaboradora del reino y siempre fue
líder en absolutamente todos sus
proyectos y sinceramente yo
pues nunca tuvo una vida llena de
voluntariado pues sí paloma emisoras en
prepa y en carrera y tampoco fui líder
en ninguno de mis proyectos y tú
pensaría así como estas dos chavas que
son muy diferentes pueden seguir
trabajando en conjunto
porque maría y yo tenemos pensamientos
muy similares tenemos valores muy
similares y tenemos los objetivos muy
similares
claro hay veces que maría y yo nos
queremos decir todo lo que somos y nos
peleamos y nos decimos nuestras verdades
pero lo que nos mantiene unidas es la
admisión que es esa misión que tan
fuerte tenemos para hacer crecer el
movimiento y el proyecto que tenemos en
conjunto y no sólo conocía a ella en ese
salto conocí a todos los a todo el grupo
del día de las buenas acciones que han
estado ahí constantemente apoyándonos y
haciendo crecer este proyecto también a
todas las personas que vienen a los
voluntarios a los voluntariados también
todas las personas que confían en
nosotros y nada más van a todos nuestros
eventos porque sin esa confianza que nos
dan las personas
este movimiento no pudiera ser una
realidad todas las personas con las que
tú te juntas te influyen poco a poco
pero que influyen sus acciones sus
pensamientos sus actitudes sus objetivos
puede ser de una manera positiva o de
una manera negativa ya depende de como
ustedes lo que hagan
no estoy diciendo que las personas con
las que te has llevado toda tu vida o tu
familia que a lo mejor no tienen los
mismos objetivos que tú los dejen a un
lado no ellos siempre van a estar ahí
para salir de fiesta o para para
contarles algún problema que ustedes
tengan sólo estoy diciendo que ustedes
amplíen un poco su círculo y dejar a
esas personas que a lo mejor pueden
pensar igual que tú tener los mismos
objetivos que tú y los mismos valores
déjalos entrar a tu vida y así les
puedes contar tus retos tus miedos tus
logros y hasta lo mejor encontrar a
alguien que ya haya logrado lo que tú
estás buscando y así aprender de esa
persona deshazte de esas amistades
insanas tiene sentido ponerte un vestido
o un saco que no te encaje la verdad
pues es lo mismo con las amistades te
tiene sentido tener una amistad que no
les aporta absolutamente nada a la vida
hay personas que suman pero también hay
personas que restan tenemos que ver
cuando las tenemos que sacar de esas
personas porque es nuestra vida nosotros
decidimos con quién juntarnos es mejor
quedarte con calidad
es que con cantidad y eso es el tipo
número uno que les quiero dar rodense de
amigos que piensen como tú y antes de
seguir con mi práctica quiero que se
cuestione y piensen con quién me estoy
robando
que me están aportando a mi vida
que les estoy aportando a su vida
después de tiempo en mayo empezamos a
estructurar lo que iba a ser el día de
las buenas acciones dijimos que no se
puede quedar en un solo día el hacer las
buenas acciones tiene que ser constante
entonces decidimos hacer una campaña de
buenas acciones esta campaña consiste en
como les mencioné al principio en
aliarnos con una asociación civil y
crear un voluntario un conjunto e
invitar a toda la sociedad para que se
involucre en esta campaña nos dimos
cuenta de muchísimas cosas la primera
cosa que nos dimos cuenta es que hay
personas que aman a los niños pero
también hay personas que huyen de los
niños también hay personas que les
encanta recoger basura pero hay otras
que les encanta forrar tejabanes de
tetra pak y en absolutamente cada una de
estas acciones todas las personas
involucradas
se están saliendo de su zona de confort
en vez de quedarse un sábado un domingo
acosta dos flojos están viniendo a hacer
cosas muy diferentes actividades que no
se imaginaban que iban a hacer y no solo
tiene que ver con el voluntariado
ustedes pueden salir a hacer cualquier
cosa y están haciendo algo diferente y
es el tip número 2 que les quiero dar
salte de tu zona de confort de esta
manera te vas a conocer vas a conocer
tus habilidades tus áreas de oportunidad
y hasta lo mejor encontrar una habilidad
que tú no sabías que tenías
y como les mencionaba antes maría y yo
que estábamos en eso de estructurar todo
lo que iba a ser el día de las buenas
acciones y queríamos hacer más buenas
acciones más ruido más personas que se
involucren entonces decidimos hacer un
evento de 15 días este diciembre pasado
porque porque queríamos hacer la
competencia lousteau pía queríamos que
todo el mundo nos escuchara queríamos
que seguir teniendo más éxitos entonces
decidimos poner un concierto y también
un mercado y una feria y qué más si un
regalo grande lo ponemos en santa lo
ponemos payasos bailando lo ponemos
pero si se dan cuenta cada uno de estos
objetos que sí pusimos en el evento
nos alinean con el objetivo que tenemos
tú ibas al evento sí porque abrimos solo
un día de los 15
y entraba así era
es esto
esto es abstracto
queríamos correr cuando apenas podíamos
gatear
mariah y empezamos a quedar mal con las
personas quedamos mal con las
asociaciones civiles quedamos mal con
voluntarios quedamos mal con proveedores
con el público en general ya no íbamos a
las juntas ya ni íbamos a los
voluntariados que organizamos nosotros
porque porque nos confiamos dijimos nos
está yendo evidente estamos teniendo
éxito todo el mundo está hablando de
nosotros pues no pasa nada si no me
involucro lo estábamos haciendo mal
entonces el segundo día que queríamos
abrir
soy peor día del año tormenta vientos se
destruyeron pantallas del escenario
toldos por todo el piso todo todo estaba
mal
entonces decidimos decir hasta aquí lo
cerramos
nos habíamos alejado tanto de nuestra
meta de nuestros valores de lo que
éramos la gente empezó a desconfiar en
nosotros y lo que el movimiento tiene y
consiste es la confianza de las personas
de la sociedad que se quiere involucrar
entonces cuando ya cerramos decimos otra
vez alinearnos a nuestro objetivo
y a seguir estudiando seguir trabajando
seguir buscando esas buenas acciones de
ir trabajando 24/7 o como yo digo 25 7
para encontrar otra vez la confianza de
esas personas a empezar a hacerlo bien
aunque falle aunque fallamos estábamos
dando nuestro 100% después
entonces les quiero decir a ustedes que
todo lo que hagan háganlo bien se van a
vestir háganlo bien se van a levantar
háganlo bien sana es pedir de alguien
haganlo como si fuera la última vez que
ven a esa persona
pónganle corazón póngale pasión a cada
cosa que ustedes hagan y es el pin
número 3 todo lo que hagas hazlo bien y
no solo yo puedo lograr estas cosas
ustedes también lo pueden hacer y solo
basta con una idea loca rodearse de
personas que piensan como tú salir de tu
zona de confort y hacerlo bien y con
todo eso yo puede lograr esto
y no solo yo lo he logrado de estas
cosas sino también personas increíbles
en monterrey que tienen proyectos
padrísimos han logrado cosas muy
este roberto y rubén que tienen un
proyecto que se llama cetera y es que
ellos crean calcetines y su visión es
que todo el mundo tenga sus calcetines
con el mejor diseño y calidad robbie
elizondo que tiene un proyecto que se
llama trailer sweet cost que organiza
viajes que involucra el turismo y el
voluntariado y crea mayor impacto
carlos salinas que tiene un proyecto que
se llama cero pobreza que trata eliminar
toda la pobreza trabajando en
comunidades vulnerables clara valles que
tiene un proyecto que se llama my soul's
trips que involucra el el yoga y el
volumen voluntariado y así crear mayor
impacto
anna sophia sada que tiene un proyecto
que se llama puente y coma que vincula
una empresa con una iniciativa ambiental
o social y así para crear un mayor
impacto
blas gutiérrez que tiene la sociedad de
mexicanos sociedad mexicana de
emprendedores sociales donde reúne a
todos los emprendedores sociales para
crear alianzas y así crear un mayor
impacto todas estas personas les
pregunté si todos los actores que yo
acabo de decirles los utilizaron en sus
vidas y todos
que si todos los utilizaron en sus
proyectos pero todos nos dimos cuenta
que me faltaba una muy importante que
mencionar que es el propósito el porqué
el por qué haces las cosas el el por qué
haces tus objetivos qué es lo que te
mueve y es el tip número 4 que les
quiero dar en cuenta lo que te mueve y
antes de continuar quiero quiero seguir
con una historia
y empiezo así
había una vez un científico que estaba
en su laboratorio investigando
investigando cómo resolver los problemas
del mundo y en eso llega a su hijo
interrumpirlo y le dice hijo te dije que
no vengas a interrumpirme
estoy tratando de resolver estos
problemas el hijo le dice es que papá te
quiero ayudar entonces el científico
voltea a ver por todas partes de que le
pongo este niño y de una revista de un
mapa del mundo y dice este niño nunca ha
visto un mapa del mundo entonces empieza
a cortarlo como un rompecabezas y se lo
entrega
y el niño feliz de la vida se va
entonces el científico sigue
investigando sigue investigando
y en eso llega al niño cinco minutos
después con el mapa hecho y le dice pero
hijo si tú nunca has visto un mapa cómo
pudiste hacer el mapa del mundo y le
dice el hijo papá es que me di cuenta
que el otro lado de la hoja había un
hombre y ese yo sí me lo sé entonces lo
empecé a armar lo empecé a hacer y vi
que cuando conseguía arreglar al hombre
de vuelta a la hoja y vi que había
arreglado al mundo
conócete
salte de tu zona de confort
hazlo bien rodeada de personas que te
hagan bien que piensen como tú
y encuentras tu propósito
porque el día que encuentres eso que te
mueve será el día que podrás construir
el mundo que quieras y ustedes no sólo
tienen 10 minutos no tienen mucho más
para hacer y para crear muchas gracias
[Aplausos]